yeah hello and welcome to this video and
you know this is wrong this is the wrong
number
is this right yes
okay um 93 g6 what am i doing against
that i go ii for actually and now i'm
transposing but see for most of the time
oh no this one yeah this is now
extremely tempting i have a couple of
good options yeah I actually believe
that after c3 riders a bit better but
the reputation of this is D takes e5
which is okay reputation is strong but
black is in some trouble usually the
thing is I keep forgetting how how
exactly it works I even had it in a in
an important tournament game once and
they're screwed to move on her up and I
had an advantage but not as big an
advantage as you should have yeah this
is possible I think I mean black is not
immediately lost here but he is in
trouble why exactly was it that one yeah
this is the problem you know that it is
not good but you don't remember why okay
I'm here
you can push the Queen around here quite
a bit like what this has to go to c6 I
can move the night there is night night
c7 stuff like 94 years to go to b7 yeah
and that is not extremely convincing
what about Eve yeah that's the problem
and that's a really terrible line for
black but if you forget how you exactly
reviewed it your even burn much time and
then you're you're sitting here awful
yeah that's pretty awful do I even get a
blunder f5 here or something with
Queenie for that's possible
I have Queenie too though I should have
just played c3 or anything I mean this
is this line and c5 is bad on many in
many ways so even the fibers of course
just better it's it's abalone which is
not great yeah anyway let's um can still
win the game from here
nothing terrible really has happened I
just forgot the reputation basically I
can't let's push this back I will look
that out
I will look that up in this book after
the game okay anyway okay night back to
age six
it still looks like a good positioner
and not not like a mean in any sort of
trouble
Wow really that's that's one of the
worst porn structures and he has a night
on aged six
oh yeah that should be nice
okay let's check this
I wonder if I should do as should
probably go here and the night will be
so nice on deform the Queen is also good
Davin hmm yeah not sure
I to e5 is actually still quite a good
idea oh I have to speed up
I have only 25 seconds left and it's not
great getting it's really not so nice I
spent too much time there it's just a
waiting move how do I handle that to
play as simple as possible here with the
with 24 seconds if possible I will take
here and play knight on to d4 then I
have a very simple to handle position
with the eternal night down on the form
maybe you should just take on f3 I don't
know
here's various ways to threaten mate
like this Queen d2 maybe I was thinking
about answering this with Queen to de
sel Candice's now very easy to handle
position very nice for my time and now
is his has TSM also yan let the clock
run down quite a bit okay
that's very nice for me
all of those moves with tempo I would
have played them anyway so okay but now
put some pressure on the pawn
nice
nothing promenade squares
yeah that's not primo really not
necessary okay King about to deform oh
nice yeah maybe no night coming them it
looks nice
stopping h4 for the moment
Ruki five and then attacking this should
win one of the pawns
hmm cannot take c6 not good but okay I
can I will win win this yeah good
chicken also with the night but this is
fine what is the best way to do this
maybe here
stop everything okay h5 is hanging
didn't take this move into account at
all I was probably not very precise
that's one of those points after
constantly move there with the increment
yeah I can't match it wouldn't quite
easily
okay so let's have a brief look at the
game yeah and I really forgot how to
continue after b6 but that book will
help the shop he has that for sure in
the book I'm really sure about it okay
so let's let's have a look where exactly
is b6 we should be three so I should do
this
Queen c6 Bishop c4 there should be seven
it can never take do to Bishop takes f7
castles Knight f6 and now Bishop f7
already works and you had don't really
have a move yeah I'm threatening this
this whole line is this complete garbage
okay so I forget I did not really have
this on the on the radio it's completely
terrible it's really terrible okay after
this black is still alive somehow
[Music]
together you see the analysis still
gives me and then is and Jessica still
gives me a slight edge but it's nothing
special the other line was basically
killing black oh5 man keep keep missing
stuff here he five how I watch
it works um I mean I'm not losing
material it would be slightly odd if I
would jam because blacks development is
really not great and he's got some weird
pieces but I mean he's fine here for
Shuang this doesn't really work him I
have this this is one of the oddities
here with the Queen and Duke yeah I mean
in any case this is pretty awful pretty
awful for back just have a nice position
right here I know what is that I have no
time and I panicked a little bit which
didn't help I think the position I mean
I was more or less moves like this I
just playing for the simple simplest
possible way to do it you know and here
black has certainly made some progress
definitely what he should avoid you
think is now then I get to take on f5
just say if yeah maybe even the snide g3
stuff I mean this is not the end of the
world
but it just like so easy now for me to
play here I was thinking Queen d2 I was
expecting Queen d2 and I wanted to go
Queen to d7 but I wasn't entirely sure
what this is because well I had like 20
seconds after the Queen trade SSL
extremely one-sided position where white
can can
try forever and he gifted me two or
three can be this is just a free every
role for playing for women put even more
on light square said that got really
nice Ira Gershwin was stronger no I
didn't do it because of d4 but this is
nonsense yeah this chick aged six Hanks
was chicken and here after this I'm just
winning winning in the house and okay
yeah I was still in this more to play
simple most quickly and you have a again
you have a free roll here you can try
risk-free and press for women something
is bound to draw a point at the end f5
dropped yeah okay I hope you've enjoyed
the game thanks for watching